[Music]
you're in my seat
she's stronger than both of us need to
stop her now I'm not a crazy or a
monster
the goddess of death
you're just the worst
all right no Rach don't get tickets now
so much has happened since I last saw
you I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh and then I
went on a journey of self-discovery
I love you
[Music]
what oh you have no idea
hello cat goddess of death has invaded
house god oh I miss this
and you know I had a flag recently did I
win
no I want easily since I'm right that's
true
as god is dead it will be reborn in my
image I thought you'd be glad to see me
need a stopper here now to prevent
Ragnarok the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
like the old days
[Music]
surprise this would be such fun
hi
he's a fighter
I'm not a queen or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
we're the same you and I just a couple
of hotheaded fools
yeah same I'll collect fire door like
water kind of puffs like fire butthole
like a raging fire so I like smoldering
fire
[Music]